all right we are live for the next dr.
Sadler's AMA that has asked me anything
session this is our session for December
and I've already got one question lined
up for me which I'll take in just a
minute let me thank all my patreon
supporters for making this possible
through their their underwriting efforts
and I really enjoy these these live
interactions I get a lot of good
questions sometimes I get a few
off-the-wall ones as well and I should
say from the start that I've already
answered so many times lots and lots and
lots of questions about Peterson and
Harris and stuff like that sort of that
the pop philosophy people I'm not going
to go into that in any detail because
I've already spent so much time
discussing that sort of stuff so I want
to see what we've got in other good good
questions so let's take a meals question
right off the bat
have you read Hegel's life of Jesus also
are there any other contemporary
philosophers as serious yet
non-traditional views on Christianity so
yeah I read his life of Jesus which is a
very early work of Hegel's a lot of
people don't realize that Hagel had
writings before the phenomenology he was
working at his his conceptions over and
over and over again in time and you know
kind of working his ideas out there
there's like a whole genre of you know
life of Jesus sort of literature out
there that's in the late 18th and then
early 20th century early 19th century
all the way running into the 20th
century you know with what we call the
quest for the historical Jesus materials
people have been engaging in in you
could call it non-traditional although
it's nowadays has become its own sort of
tradition
around for two centuries takes on on
Jesus and oftentimes they view him in
you know it was like a moralist who
didn't get into all that religious stuff
or the opposite
he was an eschatological prophet and
then the early Christians made too much
of them so there's a lot of things out
there like that and you could say that
the the 19th century was almost obsessed
with rethinking this this Jesus fellow
and coming up with you know new
interpretations but but a lot of them
run within more or less the same general
currents you could probably identify
five or six of them it's been a while
since I've been looking at that material
although I used to teach a class for a
long time when I was working for Ball
State called Jesus and the gospel
traditions where we would talk a lot
about different conceptions of of that
central figure all right a lot of
questions pouring in Daniel asked have
you had any students that were vocal
supporters of scientism that challenged
you how have you dealt with this strange
and wrong philosophical position so
let's say with scientism is to begin
with you know there's an older fashion
name for it it's positivism you know
this this notion that science in the
sense of the positive generally physical
sometimes social sciences would have the
answers for everything that's been
around for about another you know 200
years as well people have been you know
saying the same sort of things they just
gussy it up with with new approaches
every so often and the idea is that that
science you know or the sciences because
there is no such thing as science
capital s there are there the sciences
and then there's our theorizing about
what we're actually doing as we proceed
with them and then there's like science
journalism which is a whole different
thing that that would be able to solve
all the big problems in in you know a
human life and anything that can't be
brought under the the sort of domain of
science however you conceive of it would
not be a real problem or would be you
know pseudo ideas or something like that
so yeah I've dealt with many students
who
those sorts of views oftentimes it's
because they haven't thought through
things very well one thing I often do is
point them to genuine scientists people
who work within fields who were not
themselves you know scientists you could
say or or you know you might call them
fundamentalists or or you know whatever
you want of secularism and so that's one
way I deal with it sometimes it you know
if they're more sophisticated it takes a
bit more work I ran into this quite a
lot in the prison teaching in part
because there were you know all these
these shows that these these people
would watch and books that would
circulate around in there
Wesley Rutledge what do you think about
the solution of the one in many an
Orthodox theology I don't know that
there is a solution of the one in many
and Orthodox theology I'd be interested
to know what what that one solution is
when I looked through the fill okay Leah
I do not see anything remotely like that
but then again I don't think there is
one single thing called Orthodox
theology out there patrick Radovic your
thoughts on Wisconsin state Republicans
actions in this past week so we're gonna
get very political I think it's abyssum
ly horrible what they did and I am
disgusted with the GOP in this state we
used to have some decent moderates you
know sort of like Civic civically minded
Republicans in this state and I don't
see many of them left you know if they
if there are some there they're keeping
their mouths shut and their head down
because the partisanship here is just
incredible and and there's plenty of you
know Republicans who are very committed
but they are irrationally so and the end
run that they're making around the
democratic process is so morally
inconsistent that I find it disgusting
and as a registered independent people
like me are going to continue voting
against the Republicans now not just for
the next election but many elections to
come and still we see some come-to-jesus
moments on the part of the the GOP where
they start to say yeah this was really a
stupid idea we shouldn't have sold
out our integrity what there was left of
it
for you no political gain they really
need to you know either they're going to
rethink things or they're going to
implode demographically they know that
they're starting to lose and they're not
going to hold on to their power base no
matter how much gerrymandering they do
and how much you know packing courts
they're not going to hold on to it
forever and if they can't win in the
realm of ideas which Republicans were
we're starting to do for a while back in
the you know I'm talking about the Tea
Party people though they were they were
always kind of wackos in many respects
but I'm talking about a lot of other
stuff happening and then you know 80s
90s early 2000s that's gone now that's
totally gutted both because of what's
been happening and that's the state
level and because of the Trump
administration and it's metastasizing of
the worst elements in the Republican
Party if they don't if they don't fix
that they're they're essentially within
twenty years a dead party and it'll be
not because the Democrats and a blue
wave will sweep them away it'll be
because of people like me disgusted with
them and saying this is this is you know
cancer within democracy so that's you
know may sound like extreme views to
people but you know read about what's
been going on in Wisconsin for the last
you know several several years and then
take a look at what just happened after
the election by the way North Carolina
another place where I lived equally bad
when it comes to to that sort of thing
all right memento mori which secondary
sources would you recommend for a deeper
understanding of Nietzsche for someone
who's read his works well there's a lot
of great thinkers who have you know
interesting things to say about
Nietzsche
I mean heidegger's Nietzsche lectures
are pretty cool you're definitely
getting a lot of Heidegger right but
it's it's it's worth you know engaging
with Stanley Rosen has some good stuff
on Nietzsche you know Couchman of course
is an important person as an
interlocutor I used to be really really
into Kaufman
especially as a younger naughty I
wouldn't even say scholar cuz I wasn't
writing scholarly work at the time I was
a student at the time Deleuze has a cool
book on Nietzsche that I think is well
worth reading as a matter of fact people
have heard me bash Toulouse
I like to lose when he was doing his
history of philosophy stuff I like him
when he's doing is like you know stuff
it's an essays ktk Clinique you know
however that's translated in in English
might be literally it would be critical
and clinical assays and I think that
when he's doing that sort of stuff he's
got very interesting things to say again
like with Heidegger you're getting a lot
more to lose than you're getting the the
thinker themselves but that there's a
lot of interesting things along those
lines
let's see Kondo to your know who are
some other youtubers that I watch
regularly almost nobody because I don't
have the time to do it you know I'll
tune in to somebody's lecture here and
there I like some of the older stuff
that that's been out there for a long
time you know with people who who I
enjoy watching we're really they're
taking stuff like from TV appearances
and turning it into a youtube video I
did recommend a colleague of mine
Christopher Annandale recently who is
doing similar stuff to me he he
sometimes you know he does little videos
for his classes that are fairly short
but very focused they're not you know
glitzy glamour II here's uh some
animations on Immanuel Kant you know
with a bouncy voice or something like
that he's just a philosophy professor
explaining things in a competent way and
I like I like him doing that so if you
haven't checked him out maybe maybe you
should go to him let's see dick Foose
could you speak about the use of
vagueness or plausible deniability
leaving breadcrumbs in composition as it
might relate to alright co-opting so a
lot of ideas mixed in there
vagueness so ok vagueness and plausible
deniability let's bring up another term
as well to make it more complicated
ambiguity right so vagueness is when
you're using terms that are hard to pin
down because it's maybe there's a
continuum or something like that
ambiguity is when terms have several
different meanings like freedom you know
or justice Aristotle by the way in book
6 or no book 5 and nikka McKean ethics
begins it by saying justice is spoken of
in multiple ways and this is why people
get into so many arguments about it so
when we're using terms like that and and
generally we have to use terms like that
if we're going to talk about anything
that's that's particularly important
because you know the nature of our
language and the way reality works now
the plausible deniability so I guess
what you're talking about there is
saying things that have a that that have
a definite meaning and then it allows
you to back off from it if somebody
starts challenging you on it you know
sometimes we talk about this like in
terms of dog whistles right and both the
left and the right have their own dog
whistles by the way often times people
are surprised by the fact that others
understand their code it on can can
figure out what they're they're saying
and I and our shocked and upset with
them for it now breadcrumbs usually you
know when we talk about breadcrumbs
we're talking about leaving a trail that
you can follow i I don't know about it
in terms of composition I'm used to
hearing about it in terms of other
things but I suppose maybe if the idea
is you leave a trail that can get you
back to the places that you're you're
going to and then all right co-opting so
it might be helpful to think of some
examples here so recently there's been a
lot of talk you know it comes in waves
about alright co-opting of Stoicism
and you know i'll go on record here is
saying that most of the alt-right stuff
that i've seen having to do a stoicism
has just the most superficial
connections
there they like the idea of like being
tough Stoics but they've never actually
read any Cicero you know or they've read
a little bit of Epictetus a little bit
of arelius a little bit of seneca and
then ignored all the rest of the stuff
because for the Stoics there is no
courage without justice and wisdom and
there is no justice without you know a
sort of universal cosmopolitanism that
won't go for something like white you
know ethno-nationalism or anything like
that so it's just incompatible and you
know being being kind of a you know
juicehead dick is is incompatible with
being a stoic no matter you know what
what you know distancing techniques you
use or something that you might have
called out of epictetus it's it's
incompatible with it and and so these
people are not Stoics at all but they'll
they'll you know weigh in on stoic
forums and get involved in discussions
and then maybe the bread crumbing is
like you see you you know you you just
need to look at the links that they're
citing or or what they're doing and you
can figure out very quickly where
they're coming from so maybe that's what
what you had in mind I don't I don't
really I don't know but that's my best
shot at that all right Daniel do you
think rush the rusher Mueller's
investigation will result in criminal
charges against Trump or impeachment you
know I imagine they they probably will
now how that'll actually play out you
know it's one thing to you gotta
remember to impeachment requires both
houses right now the Republicans control
the Senate so he's not getting fully
impeached any more than then Clinton did
under when the when the House impeached
him and the Senate didn't impeach him
all right Andrew Hooper TLDR and stoic
week report on well-being and stoicism I
don't remember exactly what TL DR means
cuz I more or less ignore acronyms like
that but I don't have something to do
with shortening things well you know I
don't want to give a little summary of
it I think that I think that you you
know if you don't want to read it don't
read it but I think that's a kind of
laziness
you know it's a pretty short report and
it's good to read and it's good to check
that sort of stuff out it has to do with
them you know the the changes that
people experienced in this stoic
attitudes and behavior scale which Tim
Lebon and others have been perfecting
over the last I don't know like seven
years or so and that that by itself is a
really cool research artefact that you
should you should check out I mean the
the basic takeaway from from all these
stoic weak things that we're finding is
it actually does make a difference on
people's lives and the more that you do
it and the more consistently you do it
if you don't just do it for a week but
you do it as regular practice it has a
bigger effect big surprise right I mean
it's nice to have data to show that
because then the people who are only
data minded will actually believe you
but it's not something that we haven't
known from ancient times on org right so
here's a blast from the past question
from yes onus what was your relationship
with philosophy as a teenager how did
you end up going into a philosophy major
so my my relationship with philosophy as
a teenager was that I was interested in
it without realizing that I was
interested in it I took a philosophy
class in high school that really sucked
because the teacher was terrible and we
had a terrible textbook almost I'm
misremembering you know like I met maybe
my memories are too unshared of all but
I remember finding it dry as hell and
then I I took another class with another
teacher who is a substitute and it
wasn't even a philosophy class it was
supposed to be a religion class but he
started out teaching us a little bit
about Augustine and said yeah in order
to make sense
Augustine they're gonna teach you some
Plato and some Aristotle no textbook
just lectures and discussion and talking
about ideas and then we talked about
Augustine a lot and then we talked about
some Freud and Jung and awed ler believe
it or not by the end of that class and I
really loved that that you know approach
he was one of the probably one of the
most important teachers I've encountered
and I don't even know
first name I just knew him as mr.
Lorenzo he was a substitute there for
just one semester one of the best
teachers that that my high school had
and they didn't retain him and they held
on to these other people instead who
made made the class as dry as dust but
you know there was that and then you
know I'd read bits of things here and
there and buy books at used bookstores
I knew somewhat about philosophy in part
because I had such an interest in
history and then of course you know I
the first actual philosophy book I read
was Camus his mythos if assists but I
didn't understand 3/4 of what was in
there you know my uncle had it and and I
borrowed it because I had an interest in
Greek mythology and I thought that
sounds like a cool book and then what
that would have been like I was maybe 14
15 or so and you know so my reading was
kind of haphazard and then I went in the
army and and I I didn't in fact by a
philosophy book it was sort of like you
know a here's a summary of you know
different philosophical questions and I
thought that was cool and I learned a
little bit with that and then I got out
and went to college and my mom's
boyfriend at the time had the advice
that I should declare a major right away
and I looked down the list then I saw
philosophy and I was like that sounds
cool I'll do that and that's that's how
I became a philosophy major I just kept
kept at it and turns out there's a lot
of cool stuff there so Adam has a
question here which is not going to be
easy to write in this what's the
difference between Hegel's and
Heidegger's conception of truth isn't it
the same well I can answer that that
second part no it's not the same to
begin with they don't have a conception
of truth both of them are sophisticated
enough that they understand that there's
an entire history of conceptions of
truth by the time that they get to it
and they sometimes have more than one
working within their works at the same
time Heidegger of course is famous for
bringing up truth as Alafaya or you know
revealing unveiling something that would
be prior to and always grounding truth
as a tack watsi or course
fondants between you know either idea or
word and and reality Hegel of course is
famous for saying and now truth is in
the system and it's it's something that
we often call the coherence theory of
truth but both of them are you know
working with a lot of moving parts in
their theories of truth but they're not
exactly the same and complicating it
further Heidegger sees Hegel as one of
the great metaphysicians in this epical
history of metaphysics and he teaches
about about Hegel as well so Colin
Graham is a much easier question for me
what's my favorite fast-food restaurant
so fast food that's a good question I
would probably say if I had to pick one
five guys which is a a hamburger and
fries chain really good hamburgers
really good french fries that peanuts
that you can eat at the table while
you're waiting you know most fast-food I
don't eat anymore because it's really
changed since you know when I was a kid
I remember when I was a kid going out to
McDonald's was like a real treat you
know we do it every once in a while and
back then they you know there was a lot
more beef in the hamburgers than filler
and they also you know cook the fries
and the tallow from the beef which made
them pretty pretty awesome and then you
know things changed and and they're
always like constantly cutting corners a
lot of fast food the meat and fast food
is is only a certain percentage meat and
it's not the good stuff and they've been
like you know reducing prices year after
year after year had a colleague who was
just telling me you know he's a grad
student and he shares an office with me
and he was saying like he and his gamer
buddies were like getting together and
they they thought about you know getting
chick-fil-a chicken nugget platter for
their snacks or they could go to
McDonald's and order a bunch of chicken
nuggets
said well I mean that's not a bad idea
except that it's not really chicken
do you really want to be eating that
much of that stuff oh yeah things have
really changed a lot since then all
right mrs. snarky loves stoic philosophy
even though I don't agree with them
entirely I still find it useful and
helpful yeah me too I'm I don't identify
as a stoic although I probably you know
use and agree with more stoic principles
and and practices than many of the you
know people who have recently become
Stoics and and claim to be you know all
about stoicism but but I don't I don't
buy the whole package and and I don't
have to I'm a philosophical eclectic and
I take like Cicero I bring together what
I would I find particularly useful so
for me quite often that's from the you
know plate inist Aristotelian stoic
traditions some some you know medieval
Christian stuff a lot of existentialist
stuff some dialectical things some
psychotherapeutic stuff and I use it all
together right to me that that sounds
that sounds good so yeah you don't have
to you don't have to like identify as a
stoic all right let's see we have here
retro gamer have a great burger and
fries on Alex thanks that's very nice of
you
yeah there we do we are fortunate in
that we do have quite a few five guys
around here and maybe I'll do that on
the way I have to go see my kids down in
Indiana on Monday I'm going down for my
son's Christmas concert although they
probably call it a holiday concert I
imagine and it's all be on a long drive
and and there actually is a five guys on
the way and I have to get on the road
around lunchtime so maybe I'll do that
so thanks that's very very nice of you
what was Cicero's philosophical
reputation and the greek-speaking world
I don't think he had much of one that's
that's a great question I mean to figure
that out we would have to look at well
you know actually I can say that that he
was read for example you know Jerome one
of the Church Fathers around the same
time as Augustine you know he brings up
Cicero
Jerome was one of the people who
translated the Bible into Latin so
clearly he was being read at least in
Latin by people in the greek-speaking
world but I think because he wrote in
Latin primarily he wouldn't have had
much of an effect say I'm like Byzantine
philosophy right or too many of the the
eastern you know church fathers who are
who are writing and engaging with Greek
philosophy he really had a major effect
on on the Latin West in part because his
works were actually at least some of
them kept and and you know copied in the
monasteries but I don't think he had a
big effect on the greek-speaking or Oh
Daniel Cox are there any living
philosophers you think will become
canonical figures for later generations
yeah a few I think I mean like within
the utilitarian tradition I think that
Peter Singer is quite important in that
respect right so we can say like Bentham
Mill Sidgwick and then there's you know
a few other people that are much less
known that we're contributing to
futility rien ism and then I think
singer you know somebody who really took
it seriously and and tries to extend it
to animal rights
Alistair McIntyre definitely going to be
read and talked about for for centuries
to come
who else I mean there's a lot of really
great contributors just as there were in
previous generations to better
understanding historical figures and
keeping their thought alive like
you know you think about Julia on us for
example and her major contributions to
understanding ancient philosophy in our
own time but I don't know that she's
gonna be read for her own sake I think
she'll be read more by those of us who
you know want to see a brilliant mind at
work digesting you know what the
Epicureans are up to overhear what the
Aristotelian czar up to overhear
Anthony long would be somebody like
along the same lines you know with
respect to Hellenistic philosophy as
well who else might be viewed as
canonical figures later on that's a good
question I mean you know you think about
the people who are really big stuff
right now most of them I don't think are
gonna stand the test of time and you
think even about like you know let's say
we take continental philosophy and you
think about like the last 50 years or so
how many of those thinkers are going to
be really read and used not just mention
I mean a lot of people mention Derrida
very few people actually read dari down
and that's even right now so that's a
good question to think about all right
Eric Metz Lyndon LaRouche while I
haven't heard about him for a long time
and his clique or hardcore anti
Aristotle they say it's because he's an
empiricist that all knowledge comes from
and through your senses how true is this
Aristotle thinks that senses are very
important but he wasn't an empiricist in
the sense that like the British
empiricists were I mean LaRouche I
haven't heard of him for a long time he
he's really far out there you know he
was just down the road in Illinois I
remember you know when I was a kid
reading about him in Time magazine and
then you know all the trouble he got in
with the government so yeah there's a
lot of people who are like Pro Aristotle
or anti Aristotle for kind of the wrong
reasons and you read them and you're
like I don't think these people really
read
Jerris novel I think they've read some
some textbooks talking about Aristotle
or some secondary lit but I don't think
they spent much time with them all right
Zana
hey Doc Sadler I know metal music fan
are you in touch with catatonia is black
metal doom they're a Swedish band what
is your wave comparison between European
metal and English metal well you know
when you're talking about like black
metal or the other genres stuff it's
kind of a bit beyond beyond what I would
I got into so I don't know what to say
in response to that because yeah I I
don't I don't know the band and I can
talk much more about like 1970s 80s even
a bit of 90s stuff but I don't know the
gamut of of all these other you know
bands that are out there let me scroll
back up to there's so many questions
here to get to it okay way of comparison
between European metal and English metal
that I mean if you're talking about like
the what's going on in the 70s and 80s I
can say that the the England England was
really sort of a hotbed for like what
was going on in the metal scene think
about like the who are the huge bands
right coming out of it you know early on
you got you know Black Sabbath you know
we can count Led Zeppelin you know if
we're gonna count Led Zeppelin we should
definitely count your Raya heap from the
same time deep purple you know and and
Sabbath and purple were really looked at
early on it's like the the main people
who think about you know Bruce Dickinson
didn't model himself after Ozzy model
himself after Ian Gillan and so you got
like a continuity there and then you got
like bands like UFO and Hawk wind right
now UFO of course brings out a German
guitarist they steal a Michael Schenker
from from the scorpions and but you
don't have that much metal stuff going
on in Europe you know in those formative
years
and then it starts to you know to
develop and you get quite a few bands
coming out of the European scene
starting in the set in late 70s early
80s only a few of them really make it I
mean you could talk about the scorpions
as a major success except as well crocus
although they were never that good
unfortunately and then you get a you
know a whole bunch of other bands like
Halloween and you know there's a few
French ones but it's mostly German
driven and then things start moving up
into to you know the Scandinavia I will
mention Oz as a 1980s Finnish band that
that's really good
yeah and so you know you've got dance
stuff going on and then of course you
get to American scenes West Coast and an
East Coast going on at the same time and
they all kind of blend into each other
and reinforce each other are their
stylistic differences I think you can
say that there are but people are
borrowing from each other a lot and and
of course you're going around if you're
if it's the band that's actually touring
you're going from place to place to
place to place to place right and so
you're bringing that and and of course
albums would go from from place to place
as well so yeah we should probably
actually do like a session sometime just
just specifically on metal all right
crystianna's writes what is getting a
doctorate in philosophy like very
time-consuming you got to put up with a
lot of people's be ESTs who in the long
run don't really matter and you probably
make a lot of mistakes along the way but
it's very different from place to place
to place there's it's not it's not
possible to generalize about it too much
missus snarky there's folks who consider
Jesus as a mythical figure yeah the myth
assists I don't take them seriously
because that that sort of stuff's been
around for a long time again you know in
the when you're when you're a historian
of ideas you see people coming out and
this kind of goes to that question
Daniels asking there about having your
mind blown
I very infrequently get my mind blown
because you know people bring out ideas
and they're like this is
changes everything and you're like no it
doesn't Jesus you're just doing what
these people did in the 1920s and you've
got different language for it you know
and you'd probably didn't even read them
so you're just replicating their stuff
you know it's interesting if you look at
it sort of cross-culturally there's
people that Socrates is not a historical
figure Confucius was not a historical
figure the Buddha was not a historical
figure bla bla bla bla bla right and and
the problem is is that there isn't you
know if you go to the canonical text
they they by themselves yeah that's all
they you've really got but the arguments
for them being a mythical figure are
just as crappy as any other arguments
and people do a lot of wishful thinking
I'm always interested to see what
psychological you know charge people get
out of out of you know taking these
these you know I'm in the no kind of
positions so yeah uh here is what does
Heidegger think at the same time miss
Aquinas does he write anything about him
yeah he talks about him funny you know
Aquinas sort of represents the pinnacle
of of a particular metaphysical
commitment that happens once you start
thinking about things in a Christian
perspective you think about God is the
being of beings right and he you know he
brings them up quite quite frequently
Aquinas also is one of the main
articulate errs of truth is an equation
between idea or word and reality so yeah
let's see here Bruno any philosophers
that write at length about nature trees
birds etc other than through row Emerson
and Rousseau well Aristotle oh and as is
his successor Theophrastus they wrote a
lot about nature they dedicated entire
books to them you know it was it was
sort of a common theme to discuss in the
Romantic period as well and I think
there's quite a few philosophers out
there today who are very interested in
the natural world as well Jared have you
read any even rushed avarosa
so what do you think of his ideas on the
attributes of gods but a long time since
I read Averroes I read him in grad
school and then I read him again when I
was like putting together stuff for my
philosophy of religion classes but it's
been too long since I've been dipping
into him for me to have much to say
about him
Patrick Sherlock is there a recommended
way to follow your half-hour Hegel
series should I read the phenomenology
its entirety first and watch your series
or just follow along
there isn't a recommended way there
they're designed to be a tool that can
help you out you know
if you want to read the book first it's
gonna take you a while it's difficult
work and then watch the videos after
that that's fine or if you want to like
you know what I would probably say is if
you're gonna follow along with it pick
out like you know here I'm gonna do work
out this section for this month and I'm
gonna watch you know these videos and
read this stuff
I would say expect to read and reread
because Hegel is really tough stuff I
mean I'm rereading
over and over again just to prep for
these you know little sessions and I and
I've been reading Hegel for like 20
years maybe more so yeah really became
what do I read when I want to learn to
be a better dad now what do I personally
read I read I read philosophical stuff
an occasionally blog posts you know from
from people talking about fatherhood
what would you want to read I don't know
there's there's probably a whole
literature out there about about
fatherhood that that would be quite good
I just don't don't really read that
stuff you know sometimes I'll find it
useful to talk with other dads about
things fortunate and that I you know one
at one of my dad's my adopted dad is
long dead but I've got my birth father
who I'm in contact with so I can bounce
ideas off of him some of the time but a
lot of the time as the answers are sort
of well you know you do your best so
it's just nice sometimes to have
somebody to talk to you Daniel asks do I
support the recreational legalization of
marijuana yeah I'm
I think that the time has come to take
that off of the law things and I think a
lot of people are you know against that
because they like profiting on the
misery that drug busts provide them with
doesn't mean I'm you know thinking that
we we should make all drugs legal you
know let's have some PCP as well you
know know some of that stuff we need to
keep under wraps but marijuana yeah
Nicola wanted to ask about Parmenides
and Plato's being what did you want to
ask about it you know maybe that ant
that answer will be further down equi
and what aspects of plato do you find
congenial in your own thinking that's a
good question
I like the tripartite understanding of
the human psyche you know I'm not I
don't buy into like a very rigid Faculty
of psychology but I think there's
something to that and I think that that
through monic part is very important to
attend to I don't I don't know that I
think that there's anything out there
like forms but I think the thinking in
terms of the forms can often be quite
helpful as a heuristic and what else you
know the the movement from the body to
the soul provided you know sort of like
in the symposium when we're not just
devaluing the body that that's kind of
good stuff
although I don't like so much where it
leads after that to the impersonal I'm
really a personalist when it comes down
to things and I mean I just really love
reading Plato I I don't know that I
actually take that much from him
directly in terms of what Plato said
this I will say this the notion that
there is no perfect justice within this
world and yet we can conceptualize
justice that's a good one right that
that every every justice that we look at
in this world our courage or whatever is
always going to have some some side we
can look at it from where it's not just
that seems important to me
AP and the birth of tragedy what is
Nietzsche mean by the statement the
world is only justified in his aesthetic
phenomenon it means it's not justified
in a moral sense or in in you know other
ways yet they would have to do with our
aesthetic responses to the world so that
it would be how we experience the world
in terms of things like the interesting
or the beautiful or the the sublime or
the really is the horrifying an
aesthetic response perhaps that would
you know would fit in there and and the
Apollonian and Dionysian responses are
both you know aesthetic responses as
well as ways of living ways of
approaching things
Corvo should we care about the racist
views of philosopher like Kant and Locke
this is a good question too yeah we
should care about it but we should care
about it in the following way
we should just like we should care about
what Aristotle thinks about women too
which is equally boneheaded we should
say these these philosophers say some
some things that that are clearly wrong
and they could have possibly known
better if they if they you know
situation had been better they've chosen
to think in different ways but we don't
throw out the rest of their work because
of it unless it's directly tied to the
racism so like you know when you read
Kant's anthropology from a pragmatic
point of view plenty of racism in there
right does that impact his critique of
practical reasons I don't think so
you know when Hegel for example tells us
that Africa has no history Hegel's wrong
you know and that might that might be a
bit more damning right because
everything is tied together in Hegel
when Aristotle tells us that women are
you know just biologically an
intellectually inferior to men
Aristotle is wrong and we should set
aside or ignore or use Aristotle's own
work in a way against him by the way
that's what deconstruction in the real
sense is if you read Derrida you take an
author seriously it's similar I actually
wrote a piece years back where I showed
Derrida's notion of deconstruction is
similar to Maryse blown Dells approach
in philosophy the you know extending
charity to your opponents that that's
the sort of thing I would say we got to
do all right mrs. snarky the GOP can no
longer claim to be the party of morals
yeah they've they're really reaching a
crisis point where you know for a long
time they were all about like Family
Values and you know they're religious
conservatives you're gonna you really
have to go through a lot of mental
gyrations if you are a committed you
know religious believer to map that on
to the rest of the GOP platform and and
people are able to do that because
people can have all sorts of
contradictory ideas in their head at the
same time but that's no way to live you
know and and you know it's one thing if
you have your own you know like like it
says in tristram shandy any man can ride
his hobby horses look as far as he wants
along the king's highway so long as he
does not compel me to get on and that's
unfortunately what politics is is you
know forcing other people to get on for
better or for worse so it's one thing if
you've got all sorts of cognitive
dissonance between you know genuine and
moral life and and what the party
demands and that's another thing when
you're imposing that through policy on
other people particularly the most poor
and vulnerable the the sheer
mean-spiritedness of so many Republicans
these days I find really troubling not
to say that the Democrats don't get a
pass you ever get a pass on that I mean
there's plenty of Democrats who are
equally problematic but the GOP right
now seems to me the bigger problem chip
in a video about getting your PhD you
talked about picking Hegel
you're special thinker this is that
Southern Illinois University right we
had to take four preliminary
examinations very rough rigorous
exercise that's there's been you know
since gotten rid of most places didn't
have anything that rigorous by the way
and I had to pick Hegel I had to pick
one person as my special thinker so I
picked Hegel and and I was told you know
what should I do to prep for this
memorize the phenomenology and all the
dialectics inside of it and you know the
important parts of the science of logic
too so I did did anybody have their
special thinker rejected I don't know I
never heard of that happening but I
think if you picked somebody who was
kind of off-the-wall you know not not
really a philosopher maybe they would
have rejected it or if you couldn't put
together a committee that could actually
test somebody on it maybe that would
have been the issue like I couldn't have
done blown Della's my special thinker
because I only had one professor who
actually had red blonde ELLs works so
yeah all right I answered the question
about the muler stuff already wonder
lady question can we improve the DNC
yeah there's a lot of ways the DNC could
be improved getting rid of most of the
current crop of insiders which isn't
gonna happen would be one great way to
do it so it actually be a you know
representative Democratic Party not
beholding to all these friggin special
interests you know making them look just
as bad as the Republicans the Democrats
lose when the Democrats don't provide a
viable not just viable but believable
alternative to the Republicans and you
know they seem to manage to screw it up
each cycle it's healthy so yeah there's
lots always man of action
you're quite right about the GOP I'm
conservative and think the same yeah you
know I think I'm probably would be
considered conservative and in many
respects but I think conservative now
has lost its meaning for most of these
people in the the Republican Party they
they're not conservative
they're not holding they're not actually
like retaining anything good they just
want to like keep certain class
structures and in place and make them
even you know more deeply you know
regressive and they want to keep some of
them want to keep hold on just a racist
agendas and you know there's very little
like worry about the common good used to
be conservatives they actually gave a
[ __ ] about the environment now they're
like let's let's screw it all up as much
as we can you know none of this climate
change stuff exists and you're like what
the what is wrong with you people
you know conservatives of you know 4050
years ago would be looking at you and
just throwing up but that's you know
that's where we are
so all right Austin are you familiar
with Paul Val Valerie's dialogues use
Socratic dialogue to discuss the role of
art the artisan beauty
no I wasn't and you know I'm teaching a
ethics for artists and designers next
semester at Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design so that may be a very useful
takeaway for me from this session Paul
Valerie's dialogues I'll check that out
because I haven't put together my you
know list of readings for that class
it's a you know I taught a lot of
professional ethics classes but I've
never done one just for artists and
designers so we're spending some time
you know like what what's utilitarianism
what's you know dant illogical
approaches which virtue ethics you know
I'm doing some application stuff okay
what what virtues does an artist need
you know but then we'll do a lot of
stuff specifically on the nature of art
and beauty and its value Oh Adam are you
past all of your philosophical phases
yeah probably because because I'm not
like super committed to any one single
thing work like I used to be right I am
I am the kind of personality or at least
I did in the past where I was a real you
know join the movement you know I'm
totally all-in kind of person I don't
know that I'm like that anymore
so I I may have exhausted my
philosophical phases TK how do you
overcome writer's block
it hasn't been an issue for a long time
because I haven't had the time to write
now it's more matter of actually carving
out the time to do the writing stuff
that I need to do but in the past you
know sometimes like taking your mind off
of it by going to do something else you
know can help going working out you let
you let ideas kind of ferment for a
while and then sometimes you just gotta
like sit down and do the the exercise of
writing on a page I have writer's block
I have writer's block and you can say to
yourself well at least I wrote for an
hour and then eventually you you
hopefully come out of it I will say you
know I think a lot of writer's block for
for many people comes out of a sort of
perfectionist worry right my writing
isn't good enough they're like engaging
in self-criticism while they're trying
to write they're they're overcome by
like well should I write about this
first or this first or this first and
I'm not saying this to you know make
anybody feel better or judged but that
that can be a real impediment so if you
if you're feeling that way you can tell
you you can tell yourself when when that
when yourself is saying those sort of
things to you hey you're full of crap
you know this this is counterproductive
I know it doesn't feel that way but this
really is and then just make yourself do
some some writing what I think is Simone
of a interesting philosopher practiced
what she preached I'm not really a major
you know reader of her but I know some
people who are and you know she's
interesting Andris miklós Toth please
tell us your thoughts on free will
Drew's determinism and compatibilism I
feel there's one of the most important
for any philosophical system yeah I
think it's an important one too
I am a compatibilist I think that there
is a causal determinism a vast causal
Nexus but I also think that we make
contributions within it I think that
that free will is a term like I was
mentioning earlier with
with the the question about you know
vagueness it's an ambiguous term a lot
of people often mean by it things that
philosophers don't mean by it and many
of the opponents of free will say well
science shows there's no free will they
have something very very different in
mind than what what the proponents of
free will mean which is that we actually
do in fact have some degree of freedom
and choice it could be that we have like
a little window and we choose and then
it all goes back into this universal
determinism where we've made now a
contribution to it and it sort of Rico
less is around it and systematizes
itself around it but then we we've we've
made a difference
we have been self move movers and
Aristotle's sense I think what's
important is figuring out the ways in
which determinism and freedom come
together that's what I'm much more
interested in all right Oh to have you
read l Alexander Cruz yeah what's your
thought in his introduction to Hegel oh
yeah I've read koja but I read other
works by coach Jeff as well cuz I think
he's an interesting guy I wouldn't rely
on his introduction to Hegel as you're
sort of like your introduction to Hegel
I would say that among his
contemporaries John at bolete and and
Eric they would be closer to the text
and closer to Hegel than hip elite is
hip elite is like like you know I
mentioned like Heidegger and Toulouse
earlier on in this you're getting way
more hip elite than you are getting the
the person he's writing about but it's
not gonna kill you to read him right he
certainly were somebody worth reading he
he by the way was somebody important in
the early formation of what eventually
became the European Union and he's
coming from a sort of you know a galleon
perspective he thought that was an
important project Luba Mayer what should
one do in experiencing difficulty
reading source text let's say the nikah
mccain ethics can you recommend any
introductory books that help out with
aristotle plato ideas I can't because
because I don't usually recommend
introductory books
I don't read any introductory books
you know I what I do and when I'm
teaching these things for my students
who by the way have no philosophy
background usually is I haven't read the
text and we talk about it I make you
know make some explanations and
applications I provide them with sort of
these lesson pages that are like you
know blog posts handouts videos
resources to help them and I tell them
give them a little pep talk every
semester you are capable of
understanding Plato and Aristotle if you
apply yourself it will be tough so when
you run into stuff that's difficult keep
at it you know you're gonna have to read
and reread and that's a-ok
you know and if you come away only
understanding one-third of the concepts
after five reads that's that's fine too
you know people read and reread these
these thinkers for decades I have been
and so you know I don't think that you
there's nothing wrong with going to
secondary sources it's not going to hurt
you just don't believe that the
secondary source is necessarily the same
thing as the original the original is
much richer and it's worth spending time
with chip what do you think of Anthony
Kenny I remember you criticizing his
translations of Aquinas what do you
think of his own philosophical writings
I think his book on Aristotle in the
will it's okay you know it's it's worth
reading I don't think he's right about a
lot of stuff I haven't read his history
of philosophy which I said is pretty
good but I don't spend a lot of time
reading like I said secondary stuff so
you know
Kennedy was was a guy who did the stuff
that he did fairly well but I don't
think he had a wide I don't think he was
able to sir like you know put himself
into other perspectives very well in the
beginning who was a better psychologist
in your opinion Shakespeare Nietzsche
probably Shakespeare you know although I
think they're doing very different
you could also ask how about Dostoevsky
you know who's better Dostoevsky or
Shakespeare I don't know maybe
Dostoevsky it really depends on what
you're looking for you know I would say
Shakespeare is a much wider range but
what are we gonna do give out a prize or
something to these guys a Khmer B I'm
not sure how that that little circle
thing above the the a changes the vowel
can you please elaborate on the topic of
what reality really is no I can't do
that what concept of reality is Hegel
compared to Heidegger well I mean Hegel
uses the term real via click all the
time
but that's not that's not necessarily
what you have in mind by reality I think
there's a vast totality of things and no
I can't do anything with that here so
yeah
Giovanna are you familiar with Angie
house from University of Sheffield she
doesn't have a channel but you can find
lecturers from around YouTube yeah I'm
familiar with her she's she's a kind of
a name in public philosophy it's nice to
have a good platform and people the
video record you and do all that stuff
for you that's been helpful her work
seems to be pretty good you know and
that's really about it missus lots of
dog whistles being used on the right
they keep altering them to make the left
look crazy yeah there's this whole like
there's this whole thing about owning
the libs you know that again don't
really understand but anybody who spends
a lot of time doing that is basically
ruining their character that's a virtue
ethics perspective on that sort of thing
Joe what do you think Hegel would say to
Marx about the relationship between
history and philosophy
that's an interesting question what
would Hegel say to Marx period
I think Hegel would say well it's less
driven by economics then you make it out
but nice job on the economics front
you've really gone much further than I
have in your analyses of things and I
think Hegel would have probably look at
Marx's analysis of
you know what capitalism does and how
how it developed and how it brought
itself to the table and you'd probably
be like yeah you know I I can buy your
your stuff on this nice job you know
you'd probably look at Marx as being
like the way Aristotle look at
Theophrastus all right oh ok Zuko Foose
has a thing and thinking about Xena
Bosch using the okay symbol yeah you
know here I'm gonna have a little rant
one of the things I like the one things
I dislike the most I would say like the
least but no I don't even like it I
dislike it about about all these people
who are you know have their little
covert agendas and stuff like that is
how they're screwing up are are they're
screwing things up for the rest of us
right I mean I would like to be able to
make the okay symbol without somebody
thinking that I'm you know flashing a
white power sign but those jackasses had
to like you know do their little secret
Club and and all that and then they
screw it up for the rest of us and
there's so many things like that and the
right has done plenty of that the left
has also done plenty of that too with
like seeing racism everywhere and you
know I wish people would just sometimes
just shut the hell up and get the hell
out of our public space you know if they
want to do their their silly silly bowls
you know their [ __ ] so yeah I mean
there's all this like in-crowd kind of
stuff you know I've never been a joiner
in that sense you know I may have said
it was you know I could be like a
movement person but it had to be a
movement that I'd believe it and as soon
as I'd realize that most of the members
were full of crap I quit being part of
that movement you know so alright Adam
do you think people need religious
guidance are we doomed to live in
absurdity I think that the way the work
that's a good question the way the world
is it's very easy to draw conclusions
that it's an absurd world but that's not
the only way that we can look at it
there's other alternatives possible I
would
sometimes they require a kind of support
structure or apparatus
you know conceptually emotionally
pragmatically in terms of stories and in
terms of connections to other people and
religion can provide that religion often
doesn't provide that for people though
because you know winds up being co-opted
in one way or another you know I was
talking about like these these people in
the GOP who are religious and you're
like how does this jibe with anything
that you you actually believe or your
church teaches or you know like maybe
the Sermon on the Mount might have to
say and they have to do so much
backpedaling so and that's possible with
any religious framework and it's
possible with philosophical frameworks
people you know like I mentioned people
using stoicism for all sorts of stuff I
- the alt writers there's another thing
where we call it stoicism with a dollar
sign for the s and that's the people who
are like stoicism is about life hacks
for productivity let me sell you my you
know 20 step book with a few quotes from
Marcus Aurelius and then a bunch of
watered-down pop psychology stuff you
can do that with it as well so III don't
see these as you know sort I see that is
all like on one one big continuum when
it comes to these these structures do we
need religious guidance we probably need
something that fulfills that role it's
interesting a lot of people would you
know get worked up about you know the
sacrament of confession and the Catholic
Church
well who-who are you to tell us that we
have to confess you know well as it
turns out telling people about your
[ __ ] is actually quite helpful for
you and there's people now proposing
that we need a secular version of that
and we've had a secular version of this
called psychotherapy and you know these
sorts of things can can be quite useful
perhaps without a religious structure to
them maybe you get more out of it if
there's a religious structure like if
you're gonna do mindfulness you pray and
you're gonna use sort of you know stuff
from Buddhism that's been stripped down
and turned into just kind of a little
mishmash of you know talking softly and
centering yourself you probably may get
more out of it if you actually go back
to Buddhist mindfulness or you know
Hindu equivalents of that yoga or stoic
you know proce okay or other things but
you know maybe those are good gateway
drugs for people all right
John I'm one of your $1 patrons please
more make more half-hour hagel videos so
I can give you more dollars well I'm in
the process the last four months have
been very tough you know in terms of
getting videos done Haegele videos are
very tough to do because they require a
lot of thought on my part to be in the
proper frame of mind it's easier to talk
about say Augustine or or Pascal or
Cicero or Aristotle for me than it is to
talk about Hegel intelligently and I
don't want to produce a crap product you
know because it stuff's gonna be out
there for a long time but I'm hoping to
do the six this month and thanks for
your contribution floss or philosopher
ed do you think ethnics group ethnic
groups have a right to see that their
people continue to exist in the future
even if there's apparently no benefit in
preserving their rice for example the
declining white population well I mean I
don't think the white population is in
any danger of going away anytime soon as
a matter of fact you know if you think
about if we wanted to like follow along
the lines the people are often like you
know all worried about white genocide
and some of the other baggage that goes
with it like you know inferior mentality
most of those people tend to be pretty
dumb themselves and maybe you know if
all of us whites were gonna like have a
contest about like who would who would
survive on maybe they could be the
surplus that gets lost you know all the
racists and and you know wait F no
stators I don't find a lot of
particularly you know intellectually or
morally gifted people among them deathly
groups have a right to see their people
continue to exist in the future I don't
know if there is a right I mean you're
talking about like a
right that would belong to the group
right rather than belonging to the
members depends on what's defining that
group I mean I think though the notion
of whiteness is stupid anyway
I think it's done way more harm than
good and I you know although census
category white I've never I've never
like said I identify with the white race
or anything like that for a variety of
reasons you know my biological
great-grandfather was Irish and his
horse farm completely destroyed by the
Klan on one Christmas Eve here in
Wisconsin because remember the Klan
hated Jews and Catholics as much as they
hated blacks right didn't help him to be
white that did it and we can go on and
on and on being being from you know my
mother's my adopted mother's side
french-canadian are you really white in
the same way as an Anglo is some
respects yes some respects no in some
respects you have more in common with
other you know Latinos but there's you
can go on and on and on and on and on
with that sort of thing so no I don't I
don't see if you want a race to continue
focus on the members and make them
people worth continuing on in their
existence if you ask me if all whites
were just a bunch of rabid racists like
let's say they're all you know here's
the thing I'm particularly against
especially up here in Wisconsin let's
say they're all like super Confederate
flag wavers and there are the only
members of the race well I don't think
it's race has to continue then as a
matter of fact I'd rather see them not
you know so a little bit of a rant there
all right
cool cats on what are your opinions on
hierarchy
I think hierarchy often exists I think
that people like hierarchy for their own
for its own sake are often pretty
damaged and they should ask themselves
why they love hierarchy so much I can't
really answer the question about
favorite philosopher because I don't
have a favor
philosopher any more than I have a
favorite band um okay let's go down
let's see Adriana what do you think of
the hunter and refugees and Trump's
draconian attitude are they dangerous
zombies from The Walking Dead no I think
I think they're just people who are
stuck in a very shitty situation and
we're making things much more difficult
for them much more difficult than they
need to be or ought to be and I think
exploiting them for political gain is in
the way that the Republicans have done
is pretty disgusting I don't think that
we should say oh well you know
everybody's automatically a refugee or
anything like that maybe we should you
know like check them out but this this
all these punitive attitudes towards
them it's just you know it you know it's
interesting because there's this whole
debate about people who are like that's
not who we are as America and then you
know all sorts of people who are
minorities weighed in and said well if
you know your American history that is
how we've been as Americans and actually
you could read the Tocqueville you know
to tocqueville's democracy in America
written in the in the 40s right says
that America has for the most part done
pretty good but it's treated two races
horribly and he writes about at that
time the Native Americans and Africans
who were brought here as slaves right so
it's it's not as if this is a totally
new thing but it's a bad thing
reigning chief opinions on Alan Watts
people ask me this all the time you know
I read him when I was a kid thought he
was cool back then not a big fan now oh
retro gamer sure there's Eli's drone go
home or press for the 6cm république
should they through there be a genuine
revolution that sweeps away the current
french establishment and ushers in what
a new presidency with a new de gaulle or
something like that
very interesting question i don't have
an opinion on whether they should go
home because France is not my country
[Music]
I think that that they you know France
has some really really serious class
problems and a lot of that does center
around the parents versus everybody else
thing I'll tell you that that's been
around for a very long time and and you
know I've seen that play itself out with
my my French friends and you know with
family members going over there and
sometimes even talking with Parisian
French over here who look at me like I'm
stupid when I ask where they're from
because obviously for their they're part
of the elite so where else could they be
from except for Paris I think there's
you know Joan are you know what's going
on there is going on there because
France is social contract you might say
is radically damaged and needs to be
fixed so yeah alright the new Stoics
well-being and virtue ethics is not well
connected virtue is its own reward yeah
I don't think so I mean depends on what
you consider well-being to be if you're
an actual stoic you think that
well-being and and and you know virtue
are in fact almost identical so I'll
just read yours
read your Cicero read your your
epictetus you know or your you you know
you wouldn't say that sort of thing if
we're talking about well-being in terms
of other measures of well-being again
read your Cicero read your read your on
the ends book three or Cato's presenting
all of those things that are not
themselves virtue but are indeed
preferred indifference but do matter I
think you're adopting the cynic view
rather than the stoic for you there so
alright Brian what do you think of ggx
assertion that idealists are now
materialist I'd assume it's tied in with
his materialist reading of Hegel I don't
remember what the point was that he was
making he said stuff like that more than
once but I don't really I can't really
say much about that I wonder lady am I
wrong to think logic is math logic is
connected with math if we're talking
about formal logic if you're talking
about logic and a broader
no you know whether we're talking about
Aristotelian syllogistic logic which is
actually only part of what Aristotle
means by syllogism there's a whole story
there to say or whether we're talking
about you know other types of logic like
Maurice Bloom Dells concrete logic or
Hegel's logic or stuff like that math is
only part of it but you know if you're
doing formal logic they're connected
together
definitely Mimi candy does non classical
logic really matter yeah it all matters
hey it's all worth studying if you have
the time chip do you get many students
had decent experiences of the philosophy
in high school classrooms no I have a
few students from time to time who've
had philosophy classes they almost
always sucked they almost always learn
didn't learn much it's interesting even
the ones who had philosophy classes in
college when they come into my other
classes very often have not retained
much of what they studied so I'm
teaching this business ethics class this
semester that's just finishing up and at
the beginning of the semester these are
other Marquette students right they're
supposed to have had philosophy of human
nature which is like at the intro class
essentially but it has a lot it has
ethics components and then they have to
take an ethics class so they've taken
two philosophy classes one specifically
on ethics 90% of the class could not
tell me anything about ethics at all in
the business ethics class even though
they'd only been out of these classes
for about a year which means that
whatever they were learning was not
sticking with them so there was clearly
a failure on the part of the curriculum
and the instructors so yeah all right
mrs. snarky sometimes the influence from
one person even for a short period of
time can be encouraging enough to impact
an individual for life it's talking
about teachers yeah yeah and sometimes
it can even be other people like I
remember and I apologize for the
crudeness of this but I remember when I
was you know
a ward of the court because I'd
misbehaved so much that my mother had
filed an uncontrollability petition
against me and I was living in shelter
care I remember one of the staff members
when I was upset because he didn't want
to talk to me saying act like an [ __ ]
get treated like an [ __ ] and that was
the right moment for me to actually hear
the message that made an impact on me I
still by the way remember my high school
gym coach now this is something he
didn't say once he said it over and over
again don't cheat yourself he'd talk
about exercise like that you know he was
also the track coach and we we were
tempted to kind of you know towards the
end of a Rawdon not not run quite as
hard or fast and he'd say don't cheat
yourself you're only cheating yourself
and when I go to the gym and I work out
and I'm tempted you know I'm on a set of
12 and it's the third set and I'm
getting really you know I'd like to like
give in and kind of not push it all the
way but countered as a rep I remember
him saying that and that made a
difference for me all right in a new
stomachs in America I was in taught
philosophy in high school yeah we don't
we don't have a national curriculum for
philosophy many many people get it if
they go to a Catholic or sometimes
Lutheran or sometimes other religious
schools we have a philosophy elective if
you're a rich kid in a really nice
school public school you might get it as
well because it will be taught as a
social studies elective it's pretty rare
that you find it in other places on
unfortunately Kyle are you familiar with
James George Frazer is Golden Bough
what's your take on Christianity it's
just another myth like any other is
there something distinctive that sets it
apart yeah I mean I read the Golden Ball
years and years and years and years and
years ago because you know I thought
it's important everyone's referencing it
I probably should check it out
and
then what would I think about it it's
it's okay you know do I think
Christianity is a myth like any other I
would say right there that that's
already a problem because when you're
talking about a religious when you're
talking about a religious complex as
complicated as Christianity it can't be
Amen right there has to be a whole bunch
of things even if you want to say it's
all just myths there'd have to be a
whole bunch of different things and then
they're connected with material
correlates right practices institutions
stuff like that so I think a lot of that
comparative stuff is often kind of kind
of weak you know and I don't I don't
know I don't remember being super
impressed with the Golden Bough when I
when I read it all right let me see
everything just kind of skipped for a
second mobile to this is a good question
what philosophers and concepts do you
believe are essentials to learn before
going deep into phenomenology depends on
whose phenomenology you're studying and
by the way I should mention there's
things that are phenomenology without
being called phenomenology baritones
army barracks owns you know focus on the
immediate data of consciousness
phenomenology essentially Maurice blown
Dells method of imminence phenomenology
just not called phenomenology you know
it's it's generally good to have a good
background in the history of philosophy
so you need to know some Plato some
Aristotle you probably want to know your
modern philosophy since a lot of these
people are referring to that it really
depends on who we're looking at you know
if you're asking about who Cyril I would
say one group of people if you're asking
about mock Schaller who's equally
important is for several different
different groups you know like you need
to read some more and if you want to
understand Schaller well but you don't
need to read them for Israel
all right missus I'm glad there's people
like like us educating others on
philosophy with dedication thanks that's
that's very nice all right
let me scroll down there's a lot of
chitter chatter back between people mimi
asks a very funny hypothetical question
if there was war between Kant's
metaphysics and ancient and metaphysics
who would get more beating I don't know
I don't know how we personify
metaphysics and what are they fighting
with you know I think you know Kant is
doing something quite interesting but
there's no internal necessity to accept
think on Scott's position you know I'm
all what is your preferred form of
government monarchy democracy anarchy
oligarchy my preferred form of
government is one that that actually
worked for the common good and doesn't
become corrupt has a good bit of
representation and places for people who
want to be involved that the chance to
get involved people are not you know
precluded from government because of
class or race or gender or things along
those lines restricting them keeping
them out that's that's what I would say
and you know what I'm saying is kind of
along the lines of what Aristotle is
laying out in politics that what book
six or seven you know we need people who
are actually we don't just need the poor
and the rich right we don't just need to
represent a bunch of people's private
interests or you know private interest
aggregated into one kind of public
interest
we need people actually care and think
about the common good and who try to
remain honest and who try to cultivate
virtue and don't just you know make a
mess out of out of their hypocrisy
that's probably tough to bring about
else our hands just join again wanted to
say thanks for being a better educated
than my current class a professor I
wouldn't make it through this term
without you well that's that's nice you
guys know how I feel about many of my
colleagues I think the the teacherly
aspect so much of academics is
downplayed quite a bit and many people
are not very good teachers unfortunately
and they should work on that all right
Montana why should a person not commit
suicide and suffering well I mean one
argument right there is sure you can end
your suffering and then there's no more
you that's suffering is is your life
entirely suffering or is there anything
good about it you know our you know
another thing to keep in mind are you
leaving anybody behind who's gonna
suffer because you decided to you know
withdraw those are all some important
considerations else are you gonna do any
videos on the argument for and against
the concept of free will
yeah I've done some you know here and
there but I don't usually do like topic
things where it's just the concept of
this or that
I'm usually focusing on a particular
author who's talking about it alright
John any thoughts on current opinions in
the philosophy of mind I don't really
follow analytic philosophy of mind much
so I I don't know what the current
opinions would be these days let me
scroll down we're at the twenty-one
minute or hour and twenty minutes we
have a lot of things here so I'm gonna
sorta pick a just a few of them to
answer Oh keynote do you think someone
like dari dad just kind of arrives that
dead ends since it can't build-up
ethical or moral positions he spent the
last third of his career actually doing
that in books like operas and gift of
death inspectors and marks and you know
all of that stuff he once he got out of
his sort of freewheeling which I thought
was actually terrible stuff middle phase
he started taking ethics and religion
very seriously and and I've actually got
some writings out there on that let's
see here retro gamers Hawkwind live that
would be very cool
Bryan here's a great question how do you
keep up with all the reading you have to
do along with your busy schedule do you
have a specific schedule you commit for
reading every day I don't I mean I'm
sort of like somebody who's living on a
vast bank account that I'd built up much
earlier I don't get the time for reading
like I would like to I mean ideally I
would get to you know put in like four
or five hours a day reading I'm lucky
now if I get to spend you know two hours
and often times that's prepping for the
classes that I'm teaching or the
projects that I'm working on sometimes
I'll take a day off I was usually what
I'm sick and then you know just just
read write all right let me scroll down
a bit
oh okay I haven't heard you talk much
about Hamas that's Jurgen Habermas he's
written about a lot of subjects what's
your take on him Robert Moss is an
interesting guy one of the things that's
particularly interesting about him is
that for somebody who's committed to you
no dialogue and speech it kind of
overwhelms people with how much he
actually writes and publishes making it
difficult to engage him yeah however
Moss is somebody who has studied and who
helped other people with like you know
with with dissertation research I like
him he's a genuine you know that's a
good that's a good point people had
asked about like who who will be
canonical philosophers later on down the
line I think Harbor moss is gonna be
remembered he's made a lot of important
contributions so yeah Ken dr. Sandler I
want to go back to school of pursue
philosophy as a major where do I begin
and what can I expect what can you
expect depends totally on the
institution I would do a lot of research
on the institutions that you're you're
interested in going to because the way a
philosophy can be taught and and done in
it varies incredibly from place to place
to place to place and find out from the
students maybe go to their philosophy
club meetings go to go see some some
events there as well talk to some of the
professors that that's important going
back to school and pursuing philosophy
as a major that's a matter of getting
into school and then declaring that
major but you know you want to pick a
place where you're going to get the kind
of thing that'll work for you all right
let's see
so Robert asks does Greg answer in this
chat or only the patrons and then a
couple other things you know I take the
stuff that comes in first and there's
usually a lot of that and then I take
the stuff that comes later and I don't
answer most of the people in here are
people who are our patreon supporters as
a matter of fact I'm willing to bet half
oh and don't even know I have a patreon
so all right Tim part can you give an
example of a time you apply to
philosophers work in your life do it all
the time pretty much every day you want
to pick philosophers who actually are
applicable so but I you know I'll tell
you about something I've been doing I've
been writing blog entries from my son
who is struggling with some of the same
kind of anger management issues as I did
at his age and you know we've been
looking at this week Aristotle's
definition of anger from from the
rhetoric book - and breaking it down and
talking about how it applies to you know
particular situations that he finds
himself in and where you can take a
pause and where you could think about
something and you know that's just one
example out of so many I mean I use the
stuff that I'm working on all the time
and I do it with clients who that's why
I do philosophical counts like that's
that's what philosophical counseling is
so yeah let's see three minutes before I
got a get out of here and I actually
have to go see a client today and take
care of that let's see oh here's a
really good one
do I think Socrates was a troll what
were his intentions no I don't think he
was a troll I think if he was a troll it
would be the kind of it would be with
the kind of people who only deserve
trolls who are usually trolls themselves
right and missus writes trolling for
reason and truth there is no such thing
trolling is trolling it's it's just a
pure
low-level sort of activity if you're
actually trying to like you know provoke
people to think you're not just trolling
I think a lot of the time Socrates gives
gives arguments that are not
particularly good arguments and he does
that with people who are not well you
know not capable of grasping the flaws
with those arguments but then we can
look at it we can be like yeah this
should have been answered here and this
should have been addressed here so a lot
of it is to try to provoke thinking on
our own part and remember Plato thought
that writing was not as good as
back-and-forth dialogue right so he's
trying to write in such a way as to
produce a possibility of dialogue not
just within the text but us with the
text that's something that's key to
Plato's writing and so Socrates is used
as a character to help promote that
let's see here Ken Roberts can it be
argued the Continental analytic
philosophy split started with content as
an epistemology no the analytic
continental philosophy split began with
the analytics actually emerging as a
movement and then it was consolidated by
the analytics managing to take over and
capture much of the discourse within the
Anglosphere that's a purely 20th century
phenomenon and I don't know that it'll
remain you know down the line in the
future because unless you can you know
unless you can actually show that
philosophy has an application to life in
both analytic and continental
philosophers often have immense troubles
with that there's not going to be a hell
of a lot of public support for it you
know and and I'm fine with that quite
frankly all right we got about a minute
left let's see who we've got a lot of
back and forth are doing about Trump
here let's see you else we've got it's
got something easy to knock out somebody
asking about Peterson
you know I already answered enough all
right interesting question here dr.
Sandler thinking I'm going to grad
school for philosophy and psychology
can you talk about how the culture in a
Midwest college is different from an
East Coast College it's not academics or
academics and people in the Midwest who
academics often have a kind of
inferiority complex wish that I was them
attitude towards people from the East
Coast you know there's sort of an
emulation the Ivy's right that is very
common down to like mannerisms and you
know the word choices that they make and
so I think you know academic places
often tend to be kind of owaisi's in the
middle of you know a larger culture and
it depends on where you're talking about
in the Midwest you know some people
think that like you know Kansas is
Midwest I'd actually say that's the
plains I I think of the Midwest as you
know on the western side you've got
Minnesota Iowa Illinois but it's you
know once you start getting past
Effingham it's no longer Midwest it's
definitely south Wisconsin is right in
the middle of the Midwest Michigan
Indiana
although shave off the southern tip and
then Ohio and that's that's pretty much
the Midwest as far as culture goes and
and you know parts of it are very
different from other parts so I don't
think there's going to be a hell of a
lot of difference in the academic
culture a lot of it's going to depend on
you know what what sort of level of tier
that school is and a lot of the
academics in Midwestern colleges and
universities are going to be from the
East Coast because they turn out all
these these people who then we hire
because we think how it's so wonderful
to have somebody from the Ivy's and we
don't pay any attention to whether they
intend to stay or whether they they're
any good
you know we rely on pedigree too much
and reputation rather than actually
looking at the candidates so you know I
don't think you're gonna see a hell of a
lot of difference between the two
all right so I am going to call it to a
close now it's 132 I got to get ready to
meet my client here it locally in
Milwaukee thanks for all the questions I
didn't get to everything but I never do
you want to get your questions in early
on and yeah if I don't see you for any
other online events hope you have a
great holidays season
whatever your holidays happen to be I
know I'm gonna enjoy going to quite a
few of them and I have a holiday party
to go through tonight for the Marquette
philosophy department I won't be doing
any any heavy drinking or anything like
that but certainly we'll enjoy meeting
with my colleagues and bringing some
roasted root vegetables since it's a
potluck so all right I will be having
some other online events this this month
so you can you know stay tuned for those
and I'll see you when I see